good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a week ago exactly an
unnamed saboteur of the supreme court
leaked a draft opinion by justice sam
alito explaining why roe v wade ought to
be overturned
now people weren't completely hysterical
over it but actually as a legal matter
alito's views were not especially
controversial roe is bad law over the
past half century many have acknowledged
that including many pro-choice democrats
including joe biden
so at this point 49 years in if you're
an office holder who supports legal
abortion
the obvious solution is to vote for
legal abortion pass a law like they do
in democracies
it's not complicated that's how it's
supposed to work but democrats have no
interest in that democracy is a tiresome
process and worst of all the outcome
isn't always guaranteed they prefer what
they call direct action
not democracy so liberal activists
immediately set about threatening
supreme court justices and then
attacking christianity
a group called ruth sent us which is
named in honor of ruth bader ginsburg
posted the home addresses of every
supreme court justice who is
conservative why they do this well of
course to invite violence and harassment
to get them to change their votes
then rue sent us sent this to practicing
catholics across the country quote
stuff your rosaries and your weaponized
prayer will be burning the eucharist to
show our disgust for the abused catholic
churches have condoned for centuries
now you'd think that by administration
might have something to say about this
it was all public joe biden purports to
be a catholic intimidating judges by the
way is a federal crime
but no the body administration did not
try and stop this just department did
nothing in fact from her podium at the
white house the president's publicist
endorsed the coming harassment very
clearly quote
the president's view is that there's a
lot of passion a lot of fear a lot of
sadness from many many people jan saki
explained so the message to joe biden's
abortion militia could not have been
clear go forth and terrorize that's the
word from the white house so that's
exactly what they did
here's the mob this weekend outside
brett kavanaugh's house
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
brett kavanaugh is a supreme court
justice but he's also a man and a
husband and a father as you just saw he
lives in a pretty normal neighborhood
outside dc doesn't have a wall around
the house and more to the point his two
daughters are home
so imagine what it must have been like
inside the house if you're brett
kavanaugh or his wife or his daughters
the people outside didn't care the woman
who organized that protest outside
kavanaugh's house lives right down the
street apparently she's a deeply unhappy
individual called lacy wooten holloway
wooten hallway brought the mob to
kavanaugh's house for a very specific
reason not because she was angry which
she is but because she wants brett
kavanaugh to change his views and
support roe v wade she was intimidating
a federal judge all of them were and
once again that's a federal crime it
could not be clearer
and yet lacey wooten holloway who
bragged about organizing this was not
arrested she wasn't even scolded instead
she was rewarded lacey wooten hallway
got a glowing profile in the washington
post
so once again in effect our leaders in
washington sent a very clear message to
the mob as they did for blm
do what you want we're on your side it's
not like you're insurrectionists so the
mob did
look what the mob did to this christian
counseling center in wisconsin over the
weekend
if abortions aren't safe then you aren't
either that's just part of the message
outside wisconsin family action here and
it continues inside the building what
you're seeing around me right now this
isn't the answer to anything also
written in debris and glass in her
office wisconsin family action president
julian appling says the message is clear
it's precipitated by
the leaked supreme court opinion right i
mean it's obvious madison police say it
appears someone threw a molotov cocktail
inside the building
you're not safe now the christian
counseling center had nothing to do with
samuel leto's opinion of course
the christian counseling center only
talks to women who are pregnant and
aren't sure what to do next
they don't make money doing it they're
not planned parenthood they're not
getting rich by giving gender altering
chemicals to your kids or committing
abortion no they're just talking to
girls who are confused and upset
some of those girls wind up having
abortions anyway but the people at the
christian counseling center are trying
their best to do their duty they're not
doing anything aggressive at all
but because their views are repugnant to
the left their building was firebombed
you're not safe said the firebombers
apparently they aren't
so how did the media cover this well
here's politico which is not even a news
organization anymore here's how they
describe this firebombing quote a fire
broke out sunday at the office of an
anti-abortion group in madison wisconsin
oh a fire broke out really
the hill newspaper agreed quote fire
breaks out at wisconsin anti-abortion
group office
oh just broke out
according to police chief in madison
where it happened quote the arson is not
considered a terrorist incident so
firebombing with molotov cocktails
for political reasons
threats left on the wall and spray paint
definitely not terrorism let's call it
activism because you know a fire broke
out
so of course fires will continue to
break out if that's your posture and
they are and more here's surveillance
footage that we obtained of an attack on
the christian non-profit concerned women
for america that's based in alexandria
virginia right across the river from
washington
you can see a man tearing the intercom
from the wall exposing himself and a lot
more
so this just happened over the weekend
in response to sam alito's opinion with
which concerned women for america had
nothing to do they had no role in it
whatsoever but because they're
christians they were attacked
the fbi has been notified have arrests
been made no it's not september it's not
january 6th
no one stopped the person did that no
one's arrested and no one has stopped
the thugs who terrorized sunday masses
yesterday either across the country
this was the scene at a sunday mass in
los angeles
we are with you
[Music]
so among other things sincerely the
religious people are a reviled minority
at this point in the united states and
the bite administration has made it its
job its self-described job to protect
unpopular minority groups
there's also by the way a federal law
that makes intimidating church-goers
illegal it's 18 usc 247 for the record
but the byte administration has no
interest in particular in protecting
this particular reviled minority they're
ignoring the whole thing that means that
churches now need to armed guards to
protect themselves but those guards are
also now being targeted watch
hey you gotta take care of people we
hate you to take
[Music]
[Music]
so you'd think that churches in texas
would be safe after all it's texas but
no saint bartholomew catholic church in
katy texas now reports that the
tabernacle was just stolen last night
again likely in response to the alito
opinion and this was a scene outside the
basilica of st patrick's old cathedral
in new york city on saturday watch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm killing the baby
i'm killing the baby
could you get away with that outside any
other
religious center any other group of
worshipers probably not
we wouldn't support it
so maybe you're starting to think this
isn't actually about row
maybe it's about something more than
that maybe it's about something much
darker than that
take a look what democrats are doing in
congress right now if you want a sense
of what their plans are this is a real
passage from a new abortion bill the
democrats are trying to get through the
congress and we're quoting this act is
intended to protect all people with the
capacity for pregnancy cisgender women
transgender men non-binary individuals
those who identify with a different
gender and others
so there it is it's not really about
codifying roe
abortions for people who quote need them
safe legal and rare it's about something
much bigger than that it's about
displacing god as the great decider
democrats now reserve the right to
rewrite biology which is to say dominion
over nature
now they're in charge
so again this isn't just about
intimidating supreme court justices five
of them into changing their views on roe
v wade it's about attacking christianity
because christianity stands in their way
msnbc just comes out and says it
watch the christian rights decades-long
push to revoke abortion rights is just
part of their broader agenda well what
else what else do they want what else is
at stake this is not just about abortion
this is about a much broader
set of issues uh that are have that
really are about a kind of white
christian right worldview it's very
important for us to recognize that it is
christian extremism that is at the root
of the shame and the stigma that allows
laws like this to pass that allows
justices like this to be uh confirmed
discovered that they could manufacture
and then channel their moral outrage
toward abortion creating a new litmus
test for conservative politicians
references to god and christian beliefs
are often invoked in these political
instances with some saying outright that
they believe america is a christian
nation
so they're mad not really just a toledo
but at christianity and christians
believers people of faith they have been
for a long time but it's weird if you
think about it
why are liberals angry at christianity
you wouldn't think they would be
christianity has been the single
greatest force for human rights in
history in fact the western
understanding of human rights our
understanding of human rights all of us
atheists included is based on
christianity that's where it comes from
christianity is the reason we don't have
slavery and segregation and children
working in factories christians did that
so if you're a sincere liberal it would
seem odd to hate christians
but the totalitarians always do hate
christians the soviets killed the
priests first so did mao during the
spanish civil war the communists
subjected a statue of jesus to a
symbolic execution in front of a firing
squad it was one of the first things
they did within weeks of the war
breaking out here's the picture on your
screen
shooting jesus it tells you everything
so modern liberals hate christianity not
because it's repressive but because they
are
any religion that puts god before
government is by definition a threat to
their power
most offensive of all christianity
specifically rejects their most
cherished dogma which is racial
hierarchy the christian message is the
opposite of the equity agenda
christianity describes a universal
brotherhood of man every person created
in god's image and therefore for that
reason morally equal
that is gravely disempowering for the
left
if all people are morally equal you
can't really divide your population by
skin color you can't really set one
group against another you can't tell one
group you're better than that group
you're worse than that group that's not
allowed
so in order to allow it you have to
erase christianity and they've been
working on it for a long time
ever notice how they call martin luther
king doctor but not reverend
king was not a physician he was a
christian preacher they'd like you to
forget that
undermining christianity is the central
project of the left because it stands in
their way as dozens of churches burned
across canada last summer the country's
prime minister justin trudeau refused to
condemn the fire bombings he called them
quote understandable
then the head of canada's aclu
effectively endorsed the fire bombings
burn it all down she wrote
and now we're seeing it happen here as
we know it would
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight